[Music]
i'm here at coleman glacier on mount
baker for two weeks shooting time lapses
as we've been hiking we keep hearing all
the rumbling and change that's happening
with the glacier
right at the base of the glacier
currently have seven cameras
time-lapsing different aspects of the
glacier got a camera right there
got a camera right there
shooting telephoto kind of macro
small scenes
water droplets and air bubbles moving
through the ice
shooting some moco time-lapse sequences
pushing into this crevasse
look at that it's just beautiful we've
got a really nice composition going just
where the ice meets the dirt here and
it's pushing it out we're starting to
see exactly what we set out to capture
i've got this shot way off in the
distance of these dramatic jagged spikes
that are sticking up we're getting a
slight amount of downward sloping uh
motion with the ice in 10 or so days
from now it's gonna be pretty exciting
so we've reached our camera positions up
here they're hidden in the forested
ridge line above the glacier we're going
to pull cards on both of them all the
files are there everything's exposed
beautifully
whoa
okay actually there is a lot of change
especially on the edge of the glacier
and it's significantly decreased in
thickness
so this is as far as the glacier went
this last winter
the winter prior
and the winter before that so that's
three years
of glacial retreat
[Applause]
we've definitely been experiencing our
fair share of difficulties with a lot of
these camera setups this is just so
nerve-wracking i know it's really
nerve-racking just all the complexities
that go into everything batteries and
kilometers keeping everything dry and
warm and not getting run over by a
glacier
it's so hard these setups to
gauge what to expect just coming down to
preview the cameras is exciting but
makes me a little nervous each time
but as soon as that sun rises and hits
the ice
everything starts changing you got the
ice melting mud and rocks sliding down
the ice we're already seeing movement in
the glacier not only is the glacier
moving downhill but it's actually
deflating at the same time
time lapse has just been such a really
interesting way to show all the change
that happens here
welcome to north america the most
diverse continent on earth
the only place where you can find every
landscape from polar ice cap to baking
desert whatever the neighborhood there's
a hero who can make it a home
[Music]